[Music]
Sybrina reboot is coming and it's coming
faster than expected but the truth is
this Netflix show might completely
surprise you stay tuned to find out why
Sabrina the Teenage Witch fans were
shocked when they heard Melissa Joan
Hart sap inion on the Sabrina reboots
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up hit that notification bell to
stay updated on newest videos and don't
forget to check out our community
feature now let's check out what's going
on with this Sabrina reboots secret
behind the scenes let's start with some
information you won't know unless you
follow the right people in this case the
creator of the show
Roberto aguirre-sacasa has been sharing
several pictures of the behind the
scenes where de Berto actually has some
secret connections to Sabrina not many
people know about unless you're a true
sabrina fan but more about Roberto later
for now let's check out some of the
behind the scenes you've probably never
saw before we got to see the very first
pictures of one of our favorite couples
ever Harvey and Sabrina how could we
possibly forget about them they were
always so adorable
but they definitely look different don't
they and yet we still have a soft spot
for them and we're cheering them on
Roberto also shared a first look into
what Salem would look like we still
can't get over the fact that Salem might
be back but more about him later
Roberto also shared the very first
concept art for Sabrina the reboot way
back in December 2017 he commented that
it looked fantastic and chilling and
honestly this has been the theme
throughout this reboot a dark forest
some fire it really doesn't look like
the Sabrina we know does it keep on
watching to find out the public's
reaction when they heard their fav
childhood show was getting a reboot time
for chaos if you want more information
about the Sabrina reboot and what to
expect
you should definitely follow Twitter
berto aguirre-sacasa on twitter his user
name is Ryder wrasse you'll get to see
some pretty awesome behind-the-scenes
photos like this one did you know that
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina is
actually a perfect show for anyone that
loves river del Y the
Roberto actually created Riverdale
comics and now he's also working on the
Chilean adventures of Sabrina Berta
Berta also shared a photo of the
Riverdale cast hanging out with the
Sabrina cast which is pretty awesome
check out these amazing actors all in
the same room together it's so weird
seeing these two worlds merge into one
this also seems to be poison of the fact
that we'll be getting a possible
crossover between the two worlds
especially since it looks like the
show's will be airing side-by-side which
is basically an Archie comic gasm
Sabrina comes out only a few weeks after
Riverdale season 3 it's perfect timing
considering both Riverdale and the
Sabrina reboot come with darker themes
the two worlds would very well fit
together guess we'll have to wait and
see what happens
but this possible rumor already has a
screaming rebooted comic book you've
probably been wondering what the deal is
with the dark theme right the original
Sabrina the Teenage Witch was pretty
upbeat and cheering sure it had magic
but it was still a good old sitcom at
heart and the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina is nothing like it but there's a
reason behind that you see this isn't a
reboot of the actual TV show which is
why it's not called Sabrina the Teenage
Witch it's a reboot of the comic book
called the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina the comic book is actually a
darker take on the Sabrina the Teenage
Witch characters but the storyline is
totally different so if you're wondering
why you're not really seeing the same
storyline or why everything just looks
like a horror movie this is why the
comic book writer is actually the writer
of Riverdale comics 2 so absolutely
everything is being done by the same guy
if you've read the comics and love the
story you'll most likely totally love
the TV series too we love it when the
authors are able to make all creative
decisions and based on all the behind
the scenes photos were getting Sabrina
reboot will be pretty amazing all about
Salem sure all Sabrina characters are
interesting and we're always there for
our OTP couple but let's be honest we
all want to know more about Salem if you
remember this iconic cat you'll know he
won over hearts despite not being an
actual cat but the behind the scene
photos shared by Roberto makes it seem
as if Salem is a real cat no more
animatronic cat we always wanted to be
real we have the real thing now question
is does that mean he'll be able to talk
or will he stay silent more importantly
will we get the same level of sarcasm
we've got with the original Salem
it looks like Netflix really doesn't
want us to know the answers until the
show comes out because absolutely
nothing was revealed about Salem well
apart from the picture of course so what
do you think Netflix is hiding
Salem better not disappoint in the
comics Salem is also given a voice and
this is something most expect from the
series - we don't know yet who will
actually be voicing our favorite witch
cat but no one will be able to beat Nick
vacays iconic Salem voice how X casts
reacted Melissa Joan Hart had an
interesting reaction but you'll have to
watch until the end to find that out
for now we'll give you some of the
reactions from ex Sabrina the Teenage
Witch cast mates even though the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina comet
comes with completely different cast
mates it actually has the same
characters and since Sabrina the Teenage
Witch characters are the only ones we
ever saw
IRL we want to know what they think
about the new characters well to be
completely honest Sabrina the Teenage
Witch cast was quite supportive of this
new Sabrina version Caroline ray who
played one of Sabrina's aunts shared a
lovely message congratulating Ciaran
Shipka Ciaran flay's the new Sabrina
Caroline also asked her if she's a good
witch or a bad witch well based on this
show's theme we honestly have no idea so
much is going on you just never know
where it's going to go but we'd love to
know what the rest of the cast thinks
wouldn't you we have a feeling a lot
more opinions will be shared once the TV
show drops and we just can't wait
random facts okay here are a few random
things we know
Netflix actually ordered two seasons of
the series which should give the viewers
enough chance to get totally into it and
let's be honest two seasons is plenty of
time to somehow incorporate that
Riverdale crossover everyone really
wants
rumor has it got fans most likely won't
have to wait too long to watch the
second season which
makes it so much better we love having
all the seasons available instead of
waiting for far too long to find out
what happened next but not everything
was always set in stone even though the
reboot always had the same producer the
name of the show wasn't always clear
Netflix just had it titled the untitled
Sabrina Project isn't it interesting how
the title was always there but it looks
like the Creator didn't really want to
use the name at first and they
definitely didn't get an okay to use the
Sabrina the Teenage Witch title by the
looks of it we're not sure what we're
more excited about the possible
Riverdale crossover or the fact that
there will be two guaranteed seasons but
it definitely looks like the reboot will
without a doubt be another Netflix hit
Sabrina's teacher becomes possessed by
demons Melissa Joan Hart mentioned that
this show is more of a mix between Buffy
and Charmed and maybe she's not that
wrong one of the characters on the show
is Sabrina's teacher and according to
the synopsis she gets possessed by
demons
meet Mary Wardell a character played by
Michelle Gomez
she's Sabrina's favorite teacher and
mentor at her high school but because
this show is incredibly dark her teacher
apparently gets possessed by The Devil's
hand maiden named madam Satan no really
that's the name she actually turns into
a cunning manipulator who set on
laureen's Sabrina down a dark path where
nothing good ever happens
we love the relatable theme but at the
same time let's be honest this really
isn't anything like Sabrina the Teenage
Witch on the other hand this plot
actually doesn't sound that bad and we
can't wait to see it all play out in
real life
aka on scream if you're not totally sold
on these characters yet we recommends
reading a summary of the official IMDB
page they don't give too much away but
we promise to provide just enough
twisted information to get you
interested we told you this is really
really dark and totally unexpected
considering we thought this would be a
reboot of our fav childhood TV show
seriously it's scary AAF we all know
that demons and vampires seem to be the
main attraction on TV at the moment the
darker the show is the better and that's
exactly what the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina will be the original comic books
act
we resembled a horror theme more than
anything else they were complete with
demons which means there's a good chance
we'll see some awesome looking demons in
this series even the behind the scenes
photos we saw earlier give a feeling of
a totally dark and scary theme
definitely not the one to watch when
you're looking to have a good laugh but
hey if we wanted that we just watch the
original it's time for the new Sabrina
to come show us what they can do and we
have a feeling we'll be pleasantly
surprised and most likely kind of scared
just check out this comic of octopuses
with skulls by the looks of it the
Sabrina might have some pretty scary
powers let's just hope she'll be using
them to fight the evil not be the evil
at this point who knows we'll just have
to wait and see people's reactions so
how did people react to the Sabrina
reboot well a lot of them were confused
because the media originally reported
this will be a reboot of Sabrina the
Teenage Witch many didn't even know
there was a comic book out there created
to show a much darker side of our fave
nineties characters but some people are
definitely pointing out that the fact of
the show will be darker will make it
much more exciting another twitter user
said they're not sold on the sabrina
reboot that has nothing in common with a
sitcom other than the original names we
can definitely see this will confuse
quite a few people some fans also seem
to be asking for a dark drama without
getting caught up in the Sabrina and
Harvey romance as that is far too
similar to Riverdale we'll have to wait
and see what actually happens there seem
to be mixed reactions coming in from
people but a lot of them are actually
excited looking at the behind the scenes
pictures it's all about dark TV shows
and we love that we'll be able to get
two seasons of this one to decide
whether the reboot was a success or not
Melissa Joan Hart reaction let's be
honest we all wanted to know what the
original Sabrina has to say about this
it's been reported that her comments on
the show are actually a total opposite
of what the fans expected we believe
that's because people genuinely did not
know about the comics back in 2017
melissa shared a few opinions on the
Sabrina reboot and said that it won't be
anything like the OGIS sitcom she also
said that it will be a mix between Buffy
the Vampire Slayer
charmed which definitely shocked quite a
few Sabrina the Teenage Witch fans she
did say that the original cast was not
involved in the show and it's not clear
whether they wanted to be or not on
august 14 Melissa tweeted that the
reboot definitely looks chilling many
fans responded with their own thoughts
especially after they learned that
Melissa definitely won't be playing a
part in the new TV show
it looks like the og fans aren't
impressed but we have a feeling the
reboot will still gain a new strong fan
base what do you think about Sabrina the
reboots come let us know in the comments
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]